[music]
let's just say I only have Ukrainian
roots, but all my life I lived on the
territory of Russia because my father,
although he was from Ukraine, he died
immediately after my birth and I would rather
if you ask about identity then I
Rather, I feel like a
Russian Russian and as if my whole
adult life naturally passed on the
territory of Russia,
so when the war began, of course I
was not indifferent to what was happening
because, at that moment, it was
really the point of no return,
blood was flowing around, there were millions of refugees. I
saw all this on  on our screens, but
nevertheless, we showed on Channel One
such a parallel reality, we constantly created a parallel reality.
Why
should you understand that in 2
ways we
can say that
the war became such a point of no return
when it was impossible to remain silent any longer because
I just spent these 10 years, one might
say  that I hid my head in the sand and
tried to
protect myself from the reality
that we have because I
perfectly understood that Russia was becoming
more and more a totalitarian
state, that Putin
had destroyed all independent media over these 20-odd years,
that he had destroyed free elections,
that  he destroyed free courts and that
Russia is sliding further and further into
this reality, but I felt
like a small grain of sand that cannot
protest against this Because I did
not see for myself a way to go,
could
the head of your channel go to
Buckingham Palace and receive instructions
from  Prime Minister Sunak I think
not. But all the heads of all Russian TV channels of Channel
One NTV Channel Two
they go to the Kremlin every week and
receive so-called manuals, these are not
some kind of books or leaflets, they’re
just such a briefing and they
are explained in words what’s what  we show what
words we use to call this or that
particular phenomenon to
top management and the average top management is
already sending these instructions down to the lower
level and no one discusses these orders
all TV channels in Russia work like
information
troops; they are given orders by information troops; they do it.  and
they don’t ask any questions, there can’t be any
creativity on Russian television, you can’t
just practice the words with which
you will call the Ukrainian regime a
junta or there are drug addicts or whatever you like,
but as
for Putin, this is clearly
defined; no negative information is
used next to Putin’s name and
we have constantly for many years
molded Putin into the king of the Russian land.
Putin has always been good and there have always been
bad boyars, servants of the king who
did something wrong and he
had books there. There is no war, Russians are against the war
and it was written that do not believe this is
propaganda here for you  they are lying and as
Russian political scientists said, this
was first of all sent a strong signal to the
Russian elites, and first of all to
non-Russians, that watch this is
Putin’s favorite program, this is Putin’s favorite
presenter, they say that he watches
this program almost every evening,
they themselves produce this Propaganda
is called  cream or consume it themselves And that’s
why it was, first of all, such a
strong signal to the Russian elites,
look that even here in your heart of
propaganda people think differently and I
can say that about 80 percent of
my colleagues they think about the same
as me, they are liberal  views, but let’s
say they are hostages of this system. They
understand perfectly well that they have nowhere to go,
that as soon as they start protesting,
their lives will be immediately destroyed.
I felt that I did everything right,
but I never expected at that moment what the
consequences would be. At that moment it
seemed to me that  they will immediately put me in
prison, I was ready to serve two or three
years
for these actions, but events developed.
So with me, they went along this path, their
favorite path, they let me in with a
minimal fine, and then
this whole game of conspiracy theories began, manipulation, the
favorite action of the Kremlin and me  I felt like
I was inside an information war because at the beginning I was publicly called a traitor to the
Motherland and a person who went to the
British Embassy and almost a
British spy, then after a
while when I left Russia
to work in Germany, and then
rumors began to spread that I was working  to
some Russian special services and I
constantly felt like I was inside this
information war and it was all
very difficult from an emotional point of view
because I found myself Between two
fires
[music]
above
at that moment I probably wasn’t very
worried about it but I never  I didn’t
imagine that it would go this
way, right after my protest on the
air my ex-husband started playing against me.
He is one of the leaders of
Russia Today, he works together with
Margarita Simonyan and I never
expected this path. Well, we would be on
good terms  after the divorce and I
never expected that he would start playing
against me and start harming our
children because immediately after my
protest he sued me and
tried to take away my parental rights
and ultimately he managed to
limit my parental rights and  according
to the decision of the Russian court, the children should
live with him because the mother is involved in
political activities, this was the
court verdict, so I never expected
the betrayal of my loved ones, let’s say
that they would start this very game
against me
You are so Christ YouTube
it was a very dramatic story
because  that I returned to Russia and
continued to protest against the war.
I was fined two more times for
discrediting the army, then for the third time
they brought criminal charges against me.
I spent the night in a special detention center, they
broke into me with a search, and then there was
a court that said that
the dead, I named the exact number
dead children in Ukraine at that time and the
Russian court constantly said that the
dead children were fakes, they put
me under house arrest and my ex-
husband accordingly took my daughter away from me
and said that you will never see your mother again, she
is a criminal and will soon
go to prison.  and literally
my lawyer constantly told you you need to
run, I’ve already spent two months under
house arrest, he told you you need to
run and save your life, but I
said I never book from Russia without
my daughter because I will never
see her for many years later
but my daughter, accordingly, I was locked by the
decision of the Basmanny court in my house. And the
daughter, by the decision of her father, was locked in his
apartment and
we tried to connect. But it all didn’t
work because he reliably
guarded her and in the end she was able to
run away from him to me and  then we already
started planning this Escape and
literally a few days later we
ran away
[music]
and when she had already come running to me
we started planning this Escape until
the very end we didn’t know where to run
because the lawyer said that Yes, there are ways
to leave Russia but people who  are they
organizing this, are they just doing this or there
must be some strong man
who can walk there 20 kilometers
through the swamps No one wanted to take on
such an escape of a woman with a child
and it was almost impossible to
do, but in the end my lawyer
found a way along which  more or less it
was possible to run, until the very end I didn’t
know at all how this would happen
because I was sitting without the Internet without a
phone without anything and
a car just drove up to our house.
We sat down. The lawyer said without asking any questions and I knew in which direction we were moving But
I didn’t know how it would be organized, in the end
we changed 7 cars and everything
naturally didn’t go according to plan because the
last car got stuck in the mud
literally there, probably a few
kilometers from the border, but we didn’t
know that, we jumped out into a bare field we
had  accompanying people who helped us
cross the border, but at some
point we got lost there, the
cellular connection did not work and we got lost in the field,
which was an unusual field, it was a
plowed field with huge lumps of
earth, it was almost impossible to walk along it
and all this was at the limit of
human  possibilities at some
point I just
fell to the ground and said that it’s better to
put me in jail because it’s
impossible to go further and my daughter
said let’s get up because
you have to go otherwise they’ll put you in
jail and
we have to get out of here  all YouTube Mom
and Isanki
[music]
you understand this war has divided millions of
families in Russia My family is absolutely
the same as other families in Russia
because the
older generation usually supports the
war the
younger generation is more
backward oriented
so
Russian society is very frustrated
for example My mother who is the same age as
Putin  she shouted that I needed to
be put in prison because I spoke out
against Putin,
she considered me a real criminal
and that’s all. This is of course very difficult, as
for my son, he chose his
father. He decided to stay with him, I don’t know
how old he is, he’s 18 years old and is still able to
understand that  is really happening but
I hope
My children were generally faced with a
very difficult choice Because they
had to decide You are either for the war with dad or
against the war You are with mom and this is a very
difficult choice and
I would not want to be in the place of my
children
I hope that  some more time will pass
and my son will When Russia loses this
war When
Putin’s cult of personality will be debunked I think that he will
understand everything,
you know at this moment I usually when they
ask me for security I start
joking Putin won’t have enough newcomers for
all the dissidents because  after the start of
the war, many people began to say
words against this war and against the
criminal military regime of Putin.
I think that Evan was taken. Most likely,
he will be a bargaining chip as a hostage and
for sure Putin will want to exchange him for some
other
Russian
loyal regimes of people who
are now or  in American or
British prisons But this is, first of
all, the arrest of Evan. This sent a
powerful signal to all foreign
journalists that Russia has now
turned into a country where it is very dangerous
to be a foreign journalist and this is a
very powerful signal
[music]
Navalny hero Navalny hero he
returned to Russia he  with his people, but it
was clear right away that he would not leave
prison as long as Putin remained in
power, now he is being tortured, tortured right in front
of the whole world,
if God forbid something happens to
Navalny,
I don’t think that this will serve as an impetus for the
Russian  society by some kind of mass
protest because you must understand
that Russian society is so
intimidated now that it will not go on the
street probably
under no circumstances because police
structures are everywhere the police are everywhere barely
You just raise your head immediately your
life will be destroyed I have more like  there are
more hopes for Ukraine as soon as
Ukraine starts winning this war as soon as there
is a successful counter-offensive, a
split in the Elites around Putin will begin and this is
primarily what can destroy
his regime because Look now
Yevgeny Prigozhin is starting to actively
speak out against the Ministry of Defense
Kadyrov is starting to say some-  then
other things and these groups begin to
fight among themselves, they begin to
fight for power, these are already good
symptoms,
symptoms of the fact that
in Russia not everything has been going according to plan for a long time
and that this system is beginning to fall apart
from the inside, which is less
I really hope that Russia will not follow the
path of Civil  war, but for this there are
already all the prerequisites, these structures
that formed around Putin
rose to prominence in the war, Prigozhin’s
Kadyrov’s, they will begin to quarrel and
fight for power, and of course it will be
very difficult times ahead for Russia, uh,
Russia is almost on the verge of
collapse, I don’t think so  It’s bitter
to talk about this, but the struggle for power will be very
tough and
how this will happen is difficult to say,
perhaps some
national patriot will come to power in
Russia, it will be even more difficult and
tough times, but then it should be
some kind of transitional stage and I
I still think that Russia will return to the path of
democracy because Russians have
lived under democracy for a very long time, they are
used to it, they have traveled a lot. They have
seen this world, they have already
understood all the benefits that the
civilized world brings, and now it is very difficult to
isolate Russian society again.  this was in the Soviet
years and again
they are very scared And so Dronov in the
Kremlin she
discredited the Russian army the
Russian air defense system in much the same way
as the landing of Matthias Rust on Red
Square in 1987 It is already
clear that this regime It has already begun
to fall apart and security measures
during  The parade was
unprecedented because for the first time
federal channels did not even show the
parade rehearsal and the parade itself was very
short in time, there was very
little equipment and
this regime is very very scared now at
the moment it is afraid and it has reached the point
that even on the territory of Russia in
parades have been canceled in many cities, and everywhere the
Immortal Regiment has been cancelled.
Of course, a protest from below is
impossible now because the security forces
are everywhere, almost 3 million people
serve the
FSB, the police of other structures, this is not
counting all the private security forces there.
Therefore, I would not now hope for a
protest from below because this  Almost
in the history of Russia, Stalin's times have come,
everyone is afraid, they are afraid to even
participate, it has reached the point that they are afraid to
even participate in issues on the street,
if you say something against the war,
even for what you say there on the
issue, they will
definitely initiate proceedings against you.
To begin with, administrative  case and then a
criminal case, people are already imprisoned for drawings of
children by the military, and therefore I would not now
hope for some kind of protest from below
because there is not even a leader who
is capable of organizing this Navalny is in
prison, the rest of the leaders are
abroad on the territory of Russia there is not a single
active opposition left  a force
that could consolidate at
least this protest. Therefore, in this case, we
can only talk about a split in the Elite.
And a conspiracy, this does not mean that it will be
some kind of conspiracy with the murder and
poisoning of the dictator, maybe someone
will come to Putin and say  Volodya will hint to him
that the war is lost, you’re already tired,
go away, let’s change something, otherwise
now the people will just tear us apart for hiding
everything.
Well, I already said that it’s possible that there’s a conspiracy of the
elite, but it’s probably impossible to stop it,
he understands perfectly well. As
soon as he loses this war, it’ll be
his  the last day and He is very afraid he
fears for his life he We see that
he is hiding from everyone and sitting in a bunker And
he values ​​​​his life
I now at the moment I cannot
return to Russia because I am
on the international wanted list and I am wanted
a warrant has already been issued for my arrest, as soon as I
return here I will immediately be put
in prison for 10 years. As for the future,
if Putin dies or he is tried,
such people who were subjected to
repression under Anti-War Articles
will drop all charges. Of course, I will not return to
Russia.  I don’t care about the future of my
country, I have a mother, a son and
a lot of friends left there, and I will
fight to the last for a better future
for my country because there are a lot of
people in Russia who
oppose Putin and this war is,
first of all, Putin and his entourage This is
a war  not all Russians because
many Russians, about one and a half million,
Russia just immigrated after the start of the
war and they, to the best of their ability,
help Ukraine, they send
money to Ukraine, they send some kind of
humanitarian aid, they help
remove children from there from the territory of
Russia, a lot like  if there was such
help, and therefore I think that the
future of Russia and the entire civilized world depends on this war, the Victory of Ukraine in this war
[music]